There are three major defense strategies.
Avoidance.
Simply stay out of the way.
Resistance,
fight against it and
tolerance deal with it.
Okay.
Avoidance behaviors
reduce pathogen exposure.
They include innate and acquired aversions
to markers of high microbial density
such as smell or taste,
nausea and feelings of disgust,
which help to prevent infections
and exposure to toxic compounds.
Yeah.
Avoidance is a normal defensive response,
but people vary significantly
in its expression.
The extreme responses Germaphobia which
is a common form of obsessive compulsive
disorder.
Okay,
so here are some Roman latrines
and here is a yellow fever.
Quarantine.
Quarantine is a way of simply making
sure that people are not exposed.
Okay.
Resistance mechanisms are mechanisms
that aim to eliminate the infection.
Once it's been established,
they reduce the pathogen burden
by detecting, destroying,
and eliminating the pathogen.
That's the main function
of the immune system.
Yeah.
Depending on the resistance strategy,
immune responses can themselves cause
different kinds of immunopathology,
auto immune diseases, allergies,
asthma, colitis, and so forth.
So resistance can be very costly.
Okay.
There may come a point at which tolerating
and infection is less costly than
resisting it.
So consider a host and the pathogen.
There can be direct damage
caused by the pathogen.
There can be resistance to the pathogen,
but then there can also be damaged
that's caused by the immune response.
The host can then also try to block the
direct damaged by the pathogen and the
host can try to decrease the damage
caused by the immune response.
So there is quite a list of costs
and benefits involved in resistance.
Tolerance
is another way of dealing
with environmental insult.
Tolerance mechanisms reduce the negative
effects on host fitness of a given
level of pathogen burden.
They probably won't eliminate them,
but they will reduce the
impact they protect and repair
tissue through inducible
maintenance.
And because tolerance mechanisms
do not affect pathogens directly,
they impose less selection on pathogens
than do resistance mechanisms.
So if the host is tolerating a pathogen,
that is a different outcome,
probably in host pathogen coevolution
than if the host is resisting the
pathogen.
Consequently,
there is less of an arms race and there
was little variation among individuals
for tolerance. Genes in sharp
contrast to resistance genes,
which are highly polymorphic indicating
a long history of co-evolutionary
interaction
tolerance mechanisms help to sustain
homeostatic relationships with commensal
microorganisms in the highly
colonized sites such as the colon.
So tolerance plays a big role in the
way the immune system manages the
Microbiota.
Okay.
Like resistance tolerance can
also be costly. For example,
tissue protection can
interfere with tissue function.
One way to conceptualize resistance and
tolerance is to think of reaction norms.
So in the left hand panel here we have
on the x axis pathogen burden increasing
to the right,
we have host fitness here on the left,
the more resistant genotype has lower
pathogen burden and is more fit.
The less resistant genotype has higher
pathogen burden and is less fit.
Okay.
If we then look at the tolerance
concept with the same axes,
pathogen burden and host fitness,
the Blue Line here is the
less tolerant genotype.
So as pathogen burden increases,
it loses fitness fairly rapidly.
The more tolerant genotype is one,
whereas pathogen burden increases
fitnesses lost more slowly.
What about defense priorities?
All defenses aim to
insulate vital organs first.
That would be brain and
heart and processes,
the cardiovascular and respiratory
processes from environmental challenges.
This is often done by changing
resource allocation in the body.
So during prolonged fasting,
the brain continues to utilize glucose
at the expense of the other tissues for
glucose uptake in the brain is not
insulin dependent and that's unlike other
major glucose consuming tissues,
primarily skeletal muscle and fat.
Okay.
Similar to Lee.
During hypoxia,
the more oxygenated blood
is disproportionately
distributed to the brain during
hypothermia.
And the same is true for the warmer blood.
Yeah,
there are certain vital tissues and
organs that are known as immunoprivileged
sites that are protected from
important kinds of immunopathology.
They include the brain,
the gonads and the eyes.
Immune responses that have the potential
to destroy tissue are not permitted in
these tissues which pay less
for the cost of immune response.
So there is a spectrum of tissue
vulnerability to immuno pathology from
dispensable renewable tissues
to immunoprivileged tissues.
And there is a spectrum of tissue
responsiveness to inflammatory mediators.
So immunoprivileged tissues do not
respond to inflammatory mediators and
dispensable and renewal
tissues are actually
ones in which you can have
significant immunopathology.
So if we look here at
different physiological axes,
what we see is the tissue vulnerability
to damage is affecting tolerance,
capacity and priority and cost
allocation for defense and repair.
So the intrinsic susceptibility of damage
to damage is higher in brain and heart
and lower in liver and skin,
which can repair more easily.
The ability to renew and repair is low
in neurons and cardiomyocytes and higher
in liver cells and intestinal epithelium.
The autonomy,
the functional autonomy of neurons and
sensory epithelium is relatively low.
The functional autonomy of hepatocytes
and red blood cells is relatively high.
And the consequences of damage,
the damage,
sec will or severe in brain and Invesco
are in respiratory systems and our
moderate in liver and skin.
So these tissues have low tolerance
and these tissues have high tolerance.
Summarize
defense priorities say that if possible,
avoid the threat using vision,
taste and smell if infected,
then one has to make a choice
to resist or to tolerate.
Make that decision depending on the costs.
And benefits of resistance and tolerance.
These benefits and costs vary
among tissues and organs.
The critical organs are immune privileged
to avoid the cost of inflammation.
Yeah.